tout près de ce petit coin de paradis un
couple de retraités à chaque dimanche un
rendez vous qu'il ne manquerait pour
rien au monde
even où tout se passe bien comme
d'habitude degrés annie 68 ans et serge
62 ans s'offre un tête à tête avec leurs
enfants et leurs petits fils sur
internet
[Musique]
kazan - félicitations pour ton code est
un moment très important pour eux car
ils vivent loin de leurs familles
restées à toulouse à 1000 kilomètres de
là
dorénavant il profite toute l'année de
ce décor de carte postale avec des
températures qui ne descendent jamais en
dessous de 18 degrés une vie qui en
ferait rêver beaucoup
on va faire 30 degrés serge était
comptable et annie après avoir été mère
au foyer fut vendeuse en électroménager
à eux deux ils touchent 3000 euros de
retraite il ne se voyait pas rejoindre
les rangs des retraités des classes
moyennes en france entre la pression
fiscale le coût de la vie élevé
il aurait fallu compter chaque jour et
l'argent aurait manqué pour profiter
pleinement du temps libre alors il ya
trois mois ils sont venus s'installer
ici sur la côte sud du portugal en
algarve
le climat est aussi doux que sur la côte
d'azur
la foule en moins ça marche pas dessus
contraire marc
apprendre à les amener ou à marseille où
il se casse ou de se casser le nez pour
avoir m² ici de mètres carrés vous en
avez à la fin
surnomme cette région la californie
portugaise et ils s'y sentent déjà comme
chez eux
il ya longtemps mais vraiment longtemps
que je n'ai pas été aussi sereine
je me sens bien
alors comment ont-ils réussi à se payer
cette retraite de rêve
à deux heures de vol de paris le
portugal était jusqu'à maintenant une
destination essentiellement touristique
sur 850 km de littoral s'étendent
impressionnantes falaises de roches au
chrs des plages sauvages aux eaux
turquoises et des lagunes
cette terre est baignée de soleil 300
jours par an
[Musique]
et depuis l'année dernière elle fait de
l'oeil aux retraités français avec un
succès certain auprès des classes
moyennes voilà le genre de publicité
qu'ils ont découvert sur internet
[Musique]
vous devez savoir que portugal les
personnes ne résidant pas habituellement
bénéficient d'un régime fiscal
spécifique
en fait la proposition est énorme
le portugal propose à tous retraités de
l'union européenne de venir s'installer
ici est de ne pas payer d'impôt sur le
revenu pendant dix ans une mesure
destinée à endiguer une crise économique
bien plus grave que chez nous à tel
point qu'elle déclenche régulièrement
des manifestations de colère le chômage
par exemple touche ici plus de 14% de la
population
en attirant les retraités qui viendront
ici dépenser leur pension à leurs
économies le portugal espère relancer la
machine économique largement médiatisé
depuis un an
ce cadeau fiscal a déjà attiré deux
mille deux cents retraités français
alors le portugal serait t'il la
solution pour les seniors français de la
classe moyenne qui cherche à booster
leur pouvoir d'achat dans le sud du pays
l'une des villes les plus attractives
pour les français s'appelle vilamoura
c'est une cité balnéaire plutôt chic qui
affiche tous les codes du bling bling
ce qui n'empêche pas les retraités
français de venir ici en villégiature à
deux kilomètres de la marina nous
retrouvons serge et annie del tedesco à
nevers les retraités toulousain il y a
trois mois ils ont lâché l'appartement
qu'il louait dans le centre de toulouse
depuis cinq années pour ce 4 pièces
meublées de 110 m² presque trop grand
pour eux satomi le salon ont fait 40
mètres carrés y'a pas il ya un grand
espace espace bureau voilà ici on peut
manger entre amis il ya trois charmants
les valises vont partir à la cave
puisqu'on en a une et maintenant ça
c'est notre chambre d'amis donc la vue
sur la piscine ça c'est la salle de
béring des la chambre d'amis mais pour
l'instant c'est moi qu'ils occupent donc
nous avons chacun notre salle de bain et
oui oui on se refuse rien un appartement
spacieux avec terrasse qui louent
seulement 750 euros par mois toutes
charges comprises
un appartement comme ça à toulouse ce
serait entre 950 et 1000 euros ce qui
fait 110 mètres carrés
il ya une piscine de leur résidence on
n'avait pas les moyens de se payer de se
payer ce genre de chose en france mais
ce n'est pas avec le prix de leur
location qu'ils font la meilleure
affaire annie et serge se débarrasse
surtout ici de ce que les classes
moyennes considère comme un fardeau de
plus en plus lourd
les impôts annie à 20 ans de labeur elle
à 400 euros de retraite
moi j'ai travaillé plus de 40 ans donc
j'ai de 1400
2499 euros de retraite c'est toujours
sur la classe moyenne que les que les
taxes arrivent donc les impôts
augmentent et on peut sur les classes
moyennes littoral igesa aux archives
ces dernières ça c'est de l'histoire
ancienne
on en parlera plus ce sont les derniers
avis d'imposition dont ils vont devoir
s'acquitter
et voilà économies d'impôts que l'on va
faire donc 2100 euros d'impôt sur le
revenu
mille
500 euros à peu près de taxes invitation
et de redevance télé pour nous ce sera
un plus donc comme pourra peut-être
gâter nos petits-enfants un peu plus
même si on habite away 3600 euros
d'impôts économisés chaque année
l'équivalent d'un mois et demi de
pension de retraite supplémentaire est
ici ils n'auront donc quasiment aucun
impôt portugais a payé seulement la tva
sur leurs achats
une fiscalité on ne peut plus légère
anne immobilier très bas et le rêve ne
s'arrête pas là
le coût de la vie et 30 % moins élevés
ici c'est très bien c'est de faire une
salade de fruits au supermarché local
les bonnes affaires commence qu'au rayon
fruits et légumes les prix imbattables
leur permettent de déguster tous les
matins des jus de fruits frais ce jour
là ils jettent leur dévolu sur ces pêche
proposée par les petits producteurs
locaux et les plus grosses 90 9 mai
à toulouse 3 0 49 centimes le kilo de
carottes 89 centimes pour les tomates
les fruits et légumes sont en moyenne
trois fois moins cher qu'en france et
les prix affichés au rayon boucherie
soulage aussi leur porte-monnaie enfants
pourris en france label rouge
il faut compter à peu près 7 euros la
jeunesse c'est pas cher aujourd'hui le
couple se contentait de faire le plein
de fruits à l'un d'eux prunes les belles
pêches d'abricots des carottes et à des
kiwis
et en 2011 et tout ça pour vous moins de
9 euros
vous en auriez pour premier en france au
total avec les dépenses du quotidien
annie et serge espère réaliser quatre
mille euros d'économie par an même s'il
ya quelques mauvaises surprises comme
avec l'électricité saturé 20% de plus
qu'en france
et surtout très important pour des
retraités loin de leur pays
le téléphone 40% plus cher mais cela ne
suffit pas renier les normes guéant
pouvoir d'achat qu'ils ont fait en
s'installant au portugal
j'avais rendez-vous en jeu
et c'est un comble dans ce pays ces
retraités de la classe moyenne sont
presque devenus des privilégiés annie
s'offre un brushing toutes les semaines
chez sa coiffeuse préféré à toulouse
elle n'y avait qu'une fois par mois
pour la première fois de sa vie à 68 ans
elle peut dépenser sans compter pour
prendre soin d'elles peut aller coûte 20
fêtes de pamiers
pour ce faire péter
même
on est éthique les dont la beauté cas
pas de souci est en effet une nouvelle
fois le passage à la caisse est une
bonne surprise
bon alors je vous dois 7 euros bilan
avec son pouvoir d'achat de française
elle est ici en complet décalage avec
une grande partie de la population comme
sa coiffeuse et - to buy sur votre petit
salaire petits salaires oui c'est ça
fait à peu près monde 10 600 euros de
moyenne c'est ça 4 450 avec 450 euros de
revenus mensuels sa coiffeuse ville
juste au dessus du seuil de pauvreté
depuis le début de la crise en 2008
le pouvoir d'achat des portugais s'est
effondré des pans entiers de l'économie
sont quasiment à l'arrêt comme
l'immobilier
sur l'ensemble du territoire huit cent
mille logements neufs restent vides
des chantiers ont été abandonnées
forcément il y a donc de belles
opportunités pour nos retraités
nous sommes cette fois ci à 80 km au
nord de lisbonne dans une région
surnommée la côte d'argent
antonio oliveira est agent immobilier il
s'est fait une spécialité d'aller
chercher ses clients du côté des
français à la maison
koller avait joué sur les planches
depuis l'annnonce de l'exonération
fiscale
son agenda ne désemplit pas il parle un
français impeccable
il est devenu incontournable pour les
clients hexagonaux
demain ça sera difficile donc ça sera
plutôt après-demain très bien c'est pas
au revoir
c'était un client français qui
apparemment vient d'arriver il est un
peu plus vers le nord est
il souhaite voir une maison qu'il a vu
sur le site sainte avec qui la tresse
beaucoup c'est une maison d'architecte
donc un poisson quand un port elle celle
vous avez appris à parler français comme
ça c'est d'ailleurs j'étais marié avec
une française depuis l'annoncé des
mesures fiscales
les français représentent 90 % de sa
clientèle
l'agent immobilier reçoit plus de 100 ml
par semaine
venus de france comme celui ci nous
alors immigré au portugal pour fuir la
grisaille le marasme du nord l'est de la
france où j'habite
bonjour en état le couple de jeunes
retraités français de 63 ans et on
aimerait acheter au portugal je voudrais
avoir plus de photos et de
renseignements sur cette maison est là
et sur la fiscalité au portugal voilà
c'est ça c'est le type x a normalement
c'est c'est souvent ça quand on lit ce
matin là un couple d'alsaciens l'a
contacté pour visiter des villes là
thiery est entrepreneur dans le bâtiment
sa femme claudine aide soignante
il compte prendre leur retraite d'ici
trois ans et alléchés par les prix de
l'immobilier il s'installerait bien au
portugal c'est assez protégé non protégé
du vent protéger aussi démarré donc
c'est quelque chose plus plus qu'a donc
un endroit c'est assez privilégié ici
sur toute la côte d'argent avec antonio
oliveira
il vous faire leur toute première visite
comme vous connaissez pas encore la
région c'est assez intéressant de voir
un petit peu ou en institut
il ya des restaurants de restaurant vers
l'eau et après il ya plusieurs
restaurants et cafés ici dans thor le
bas vers le village
nos futurs retraités ne savent pas
encore précisément ce qu'ils cherchent
mais une maison d'architecte comme
celles ci pourraient les intéresser
alors c'est parti elle est très belle
j'aime beaucoup au rez de chaussée un
salon de 30 mètres carrés baigné de
lumière du chauffage au sol et une
grande cuisine toute équipée claudie et
thiery les futurs retraités alsaciens
sont épatés par la qualité des finitions
je connais pas vraiment les tarifs au
portugal mais par rapport à ce que je
connais chez nous c'est correct et
premières pointes folles moi je cherche
à la
je peux me sentir bien sûr tout l'hiver
cette maison est sur le marché depuis sa
construction il ya trois ans le
promoteur on avait construit deux à
l'identique
juste avant la crise si la première a
trouvé preneur à 260 milles euros
celle-ci lui rester sur les bras
aujourd'hui le constructeur n'a pas
d'autre choix que de la brader elle est
mise en vente à 210 mille euros j'avais
quasiment vendu cette maison un couple
de portugais
mais les banques ont commencé à fermer
les robinets depuis ce jour là il ya
bien des visites mais on me fait des
offres beaucoup trop basses que ce que
j'aimerais en tirer tour je la vends 210
mille euros et je ne peux pas descendre
en dessous sinon je vais perdre de
l'argent
je ne veux pas perdre plus d'argent mais
c'est un peu plus loin que le couple va
avoir un coup de coeur
à deux pas de là à san martino de porto
antonio oliveira leur présente ce projet
immobilier qui est en train de sortir de
tel c'est un petit quartier avec une
vingtaine de maisons mitoyennes donnant
sur la mer ici les trois quarts des
clients sont des retraités expatriés
donc ici c'est un couple de français non
lui il est déjà retraités elle pas
encore après on avait en à emmanuel qui
est français n'ont donc les comptables
après la belge est encore belge
et voilà ce qu'ils sont venus chercher
dans ce nouveau quartier une vue et des
prestations haut de gamme vous achetez
la vue pour s'offrir ce goût de mer
certes un peu lointain et cette terrasse
avec piscine
il faut débourser moins de trois cent
mille euros thiery sait bien qu'à ce
prix là il ne trouvera jamais
l'équivalent en france je sais pas quand
est ce que ça vaut là on n'est pas dans
les millions je crois me semble le
couple pourrait avoir trouvé le bien
qu'ils sont venus chercher pour leur
retraite
mais dans ce pays qui étaient mises à
genoux par la crise les dépenses
publiques ont dû être drastiquement
réduite ce qui peut occasionner quelques
mauvaises surprises
[Musique]
retour au sud du portugal en algarve
notre couple de retraité toulousain doit
se rendre à l'hôpital public le plus
proche pour obtenir un rendez vous avec
un ophtalmologue serge doit-on voir un
régulièrement pour soigner son glaucome
grâce à leur retraite comme ils cotisent
toujours à la sécurité sociale française
ils pourront facilement être remboursé
en se faisant soigner ici je dois faire
des examens tous les tous les six mois
donc j'espère avoir emmené vos dc dc
octobre
il est 9 heures lorsque notre couple de
retraités arrivent à l'hôpital public
une quinzaine de patients font déjà la
queue à l'accueil
un panneau indique le délai d'attenté
théorique en cas d'urgence mais depuis
la crise ce service est surchargé et a
même dû fermer ses portes pendant trois
jours en juillet dernier ce jour là
serge pense obtenir un rendez vous
rapidement c'est quoi ça mais il a vite
déchanté
quel de 50
il est mis sur une liste d'attentes et
devra patienter plusieurs mois pour
obtenir un rendez vous
vont m'envoyer le
le rendez vous par par mail donc selon
la disponibilité de l'ophtalmologiste
pour nous c'est le gros problème ici
c'est la qualité des soins
car depuis le début de la crise
d'énormes coupes budgétaires ont été
faites dans le système de santé malgré
les protestations
cela s'est traduit par plusieurs
fermetures de services hospitaliers et
la suppression de postes de soignants
rien qu en algarve il manque 200
médecins cet hôpital fonctionne avec à
peine un médecin urgentiste et il n'y a
plus assez de matériel pour travailler
en toute sécurité
désormais au portugal il y a d'un côté
un système de santé pour tous ceux
durement impactée par la crise et de
l'autre un système parallèle pour ceux
qui peuvent se payer le business des
cliniques privées en plein essor et
comme beaucoup de retraités les français
vont devoir se rabattre sur ces
établissements c'est ce qui est arrivé
un expatrié britannique
nous l'avons rencontré dans une clinique
près de faro en sautant dans ma piscine
je me suis brisé le genou juste à ce
niveau là d'abord envoyé à l'hôpital
public de faro je devais impérativement
être opéré dans les cinq jours
il ne pouvait pas pratiqué
l'intervention dans les délais alors mon
assurance m'envoyer dans cette clinique
privée dans cet établissement
graham smith a été opéré le jour même
pour bénéficier de cette médecine privée
cela coûtera une mutuelle à nous
retraités toulousain elles sont ici
entre 15 et 20% plus cher mais pour
l'instant cela n'entame pas leur
enthousiasme
et leur bonheur sera complet quand ils
seront parvenus à se faire des amis
portugais portugais méthodes express bon
allez on va répéter tu fais celui là
alors ils apprennent la langue depuis
leur installation
le couple n'a pas réussi à tisser de
liens avec les habitants du coin pour se
faire comprendre un minimum en portugais
ils s'astreignent à une demi heure de
cours tous les matins comme star je
travail en brigade
c'est difficile quand je vois des jeux
partout entendez chez partouche n'y a
pas de chaussée après c'est la
prononciation pas répéter pour annie ce
n'est pas simple d'apprendre une langue
pour la première fois à 68 ans
à mon époque
c'était pas obligatoire il argué j'ai
pas de lendemain ça nous fait pas peur
de vous y mettre
à 68 ans ben non parce que
je suis motivé parce que oui 10ème ce
pays
je l apprécie non si on peut les
approcher sur meu discuter avec eux si
on veut s'intégrer aux autres pays il
faudra qu'on fasse le le pas et il faut
qu'on apprenne encore et pour apprendre
plus vite
quoi de mieux que de sortir le soir il
est 20 heures et ils ont décidé de dîner
au restaurant sur le bord de mer
les auberges ne manquent pas à des prix
très attractifs alors nous retraités
peuvent s'offrir fréquemment ce petit
plaisir
[Musique]
ah oui
alors maintenant je vous fais confiance
du bar grillé des crevettes de la
daurade au portugal notre couple de
retraités profitent au maximum du
pouvoir d'achat retrouver
[Musique]
mais pour l'instant il dîne avec
d'autres français
pas facile de couper complètement les
ponts avec son pays d'origine
cergy annie hf chacune de leur journée
par une marche nocturne en bord de mer
csssrn je profite de l'instant présent
parce que j'ai jamais aussi bien donc je
me rappelle n'ont jamais été aussi bien
que que la voilà
ils pourront profiter de cette
exonération fiscale pendant dix ans
c'est ce que le portugal a prévu
et le pays attend près de vingt mille
retraités européens d'ici fin 2015